how do you deal with people backseating
you while you're building it do you have
people like telling you what to do oh
there are people every time i punch them
in the face
i just shut up no one told me what to do
i'm a delinquent i do what i want to do
oh my god i will send it i will do what
i want but i'm going to stand up
[Music]
as if like as if like game back seating
was already like the worst thing ever
could you imagine someone being like um
you you haven't sanded this part enough
i didn't realize what would be the worst
thing to have a backseating experience
with until it happened and it's chess
chess is by far the worst game to play
on stream because of backseating
everyone is like e4 e4 e3 everyone just
says [ __ ] i can't believe you made that
move sometimes i wish people didn't know
how to play chess
maybe they wouldn't back sheets so much
like playing chess because i remember
when i played chess in like the chess
tournament i had to like learn to not
look at the chat because
like you know you know that sinking
feeling where you've just moved the
piece
and you've realized you've just like
hung a queen or something like that yeah
that's like playing with chat is just
that feeling but just constantly yeah
right
are you a chess player no i i know
nothing about chess
did you know any like strategy board
games like mahjong or
it got to the point where i bought a
mahjong table for my wow yeah i'll
eventually play it yeah we need to get
connor oh yeah stream let's go stream
let's go
stream hell yeah hell yeah you know if
we played enough eventually the viewers
are going to learn the rules of the game
yeah because yeah i mean i saw you
streaming mahjong and uh like how how
much were the viewers able to follow
along like like ten percent
ten percent of them like yeah i saw my i
saw my grandma playing this once
before but yeah i think it's like it's
one of those games where like the more
you watch someone play it the more you
start to just understand the game like
because like i'm not necessarily like
good at the game yeah but i've gotten to
the point now where i watch like
professionals playing it on youtube and
just watching them play it is like oh
[ __ ] now i like understand more now
about like the strategies of the game
like trash talk in the middle of the
match no they're super quiet
i wish it was like poker where they're
just like talking [ __ ] to each other the
whole time
yeah we can do that we can start it it's
like it's like the [ __ ]
that's pretty cringe bro
do you only play like online mahjong or
have you ever played with real tiles as
well with i've never played with the
real ones i only only the online my
download series oh yeah you learned it
from yakuza i think i i think everyone
learns it from that though they teach
you in it how to play it yeah so in
every everyday
game there's like a place where you can
go and play mahjong in the game it's
like a tutorial it's a mini game it's
like a mini game because this is the
thing where is the best place to learn
how to play major i learned it through
the uh you know on the nintendo switch
there's the 50 classic board games
that's how you learn to play music yeah
and they have mahjong on there and i was
like i'm going to give it a go and then
i just got into it from there yeah it's
like a tutorial yeah yeah yeah if
anything like online games are the way
to go because i didn't realize this
until joey invited me over to play like
physical mahjong how much online games
hold your hand to like tell you what's
going on and uh what you can put down
and what like the strats are right so i
remember i was like a complete beginner
at mahjong barely knew the rules play
once with like joey and suddenly like
you know it was like training with the
master and then going back to the novice
level when i played online again i was
like wait they highlight all the tars
for you
and they tell you all the hands what
what is this what is this baby mode that
i'm playing right yeah because like the
one time i played it like irl was gone
we had like one of our friends who's
like way better at it um and like i
think i learned like 20 new rules just
from that like short session i was like
oh
you can do that
if you drop a child you got three
seconds to eat it yeah yeah i'm not
gonna pretend i understand all the rules
because like there are some hands where
you know it's so deep yeah yeah marky
would do something and he'd suddenly get
like 10 times the amount of points i was
getting and i'm just like you know i'm
just i'm just gonna let this happen i
don't i don't know what's going on uh
but i'm having fun it's it's it's one
experience we're having fun yeah this is
rule number one have fun
oh my gosh
do you want to instantly sound like a
boomer that's all you have to say
have you ever done any mahjong streams
yourself or is it just a private thing i
did it yesterday oh really okay yeah
with my viewers i i play with my viewers
really fun always having fun do they not
like did they not stream snipe you
though if you're playing with viewers
they
um because i did a once on stream and
like two guy yeah i got stream sniped
i've heard that before yeah yeah but
like there's nothing more frustrating
than getting streamed tonight with
mahjong it's like getting strange snipe
with poker well they can look at your
stuff yeah they can look at my hand just
on stream it's the worst i just trust
them and
look at my
you put a lot of trust in you my gun
jealous dreams
your viewers are nice i i would you say
that uh the japanese audience is very
polite in that sense then they won't
stream stamp you're trying to [ __ ]
around with you yeah well that's good vr
my view my chat loves to [ __ ] ruin my
day
that's what they get off one day i'm
kidding i love your chat but [ __ ] you
chad
my god
oh my god yeah that's that's basically
like a lot of western people just like
especially with our audience they love
to troll us yeah that's that's where the
content is for us i guess right exactly
exactly viewer interaction
so like what are your favorite types of
streams that you do
my favorite types of streams yeah
types
types like just chatting or games or
or gun plugs
i'm into gunpla right now so i really
enjoy gunpla
um
but if you could do only one type of
string
for the rest of your career what
whatever
then i play games games yeah games like
arc and survival stuff you like arc
right yeah i love arc i couldn't get
into that game i wish i could have tried
it what's what is that game
it's a survival crafting
dinosaurs
isn't it kind of like a real minecraft
i think so why are you guys laughing
it's like squid game
i i only know arc right because it was
like my friends who played the like
four xd strategy games those types of
games what are they
basically strategy on like on like meth
it's like strategy games like times a
thousand yeah like they're very hard
what they called like it makes civ look
like it's for babies like these i've got
there's a bunch that i have downloaded
because i try to play them but they're
learning them are way too different yeah
yeah those types of friends i have that
love those games love ark and i was like
that's a good sign for me to not go near
ark because their game taste is like
horrible it's like minecraft but there's
like there's like dinosaurs in it yeah
there's dinosaurs in it you're like
a caveman right you have one minute to
sell us on ark oh oh no
time starts now don't you want to punch
those trees and make your own house
arc is for you
yeah what else can you do an arc you can
poop with your clothes on
you guys have an obsession with this
have you ever wanted to play minecraft
but poop at the same time
um i think so there's a toilet and you
can poop in it
why are you sorry are you why are you
hitting the piece so hard though
what's going on i've never i've never
heard poop said it was such a hard key
before jesus casa
so so far uh
so far the benefits to arc uh you can
poop
i mean trash takes viewers should love
that right yeah trash takes views
so you got ah what else you into
i'm into arc and you know conan exiles
you ever heard of
so it's like minecraft okay okay what
else what else do you like
you're not into apex legends the one
that every game every gamer in japan is
playing right now
do you like fps
i do like it but i'm so bad at it i'm
not good at it
sounds like you like the crafting kind
of games sandbox games like crafting
in-game and irl yeah exactly
that makes sense i'm a crafting person
have you ever played subnautica
yeah i love that game oh that's crafting
barney
oh my god finally finds a subtle wicket
does it just
it's hella fun
okay
okay so it's like minecraft
okay i was gonna say i'm sorry
it's kind of like minecraft but you
can't poop in it unfortunately so uh
so you know that's all that's uh some
that's a tick off but it's basically
like a
survival crafting game where
if you wanna experience like
talasophobia without experiencing
talasophobia right it actually like it
it's like a
fear of like open water yeah did you
learn that from that game no i literally
it okay
how often do you say that
as often as i say archipelago
[ __ ] no [ __ ] off don't did you know
that word
yeah exactly
no get out of here don't worry
you don't know this word
i actually learned it because because i
played subnautica and then you know
youtube algorithm works in mysterious
ways and suddenly i started getting
recommended videos about
telassophobiaphobia simulator and it's
just like ah that's the thing that i
feel when i play subnautica so it's
basically just you know a fear of open
water so it's like if you see an image
and it's just
you submerge in the ocean and you can't
see an island or anything like that or
you just see like deep water that you
can't see the bottom that's kind of that
kind of like subnautica gives you such a
good feeling or such a great feeling of
that god i can't imagine that in vr
that'd be [ __ ] terrible yeah yeah
yeah yeah so it's actually i don't think
it's actually meant to be a horror game
but my god there are some moments that
that [ __ ] scared i thought it was a
horror game it looks like a horror
everyone's so scared playing were you
scared
it's it's really scary when you have to
go deep down to find something that you
know it's it's there's there's a lot of
things hidden in the deep water yeah
because i've seen so many clips in
subnautica where just like you just be
swimming and then just like a shark
three frames right yeah that's like the
most famous part of it yeah yeah yeah
yeah
so so like well you start off in south
north korea in like the shallow area
right where you know the kiddie pool the
you can see the sunlight there's coral
around you're like yeah this is cool i
love i love scuba diving this is awesome
and then you kind of realize soon after
that some of the things that you need to
craft aren't in this area that you're in
so you look over to
the area next to it and it's just
darkness and then you soon realize that
you're gonna have to build up the
courage to go in that new area so it's
finding nemo simulator kind of yeah kind
of kind of and what it does such a great
job at is just it's the fear of the
unknown right because you don't know
exactly what's in the water but
sometimes you you hear a sound you look
around and you're like what the [ __ ]
going on you know you're checking
around
computer
yeah because i like normally i [ __ ]
hate horror games right because i hate
jump scares i hate jump scares the most
and uh yeah subnautica i mean it doesn't
intentionally give you jump scares
obviously natural jumps it's you know
it's a natural jump scare but uh like it
does give you this feeling of just
uneasiness like you're swimming in the
ocean and you feel someone grabbing your
feet
that kind of feeling you know
um so it's and it's it's just a very fun
crafting survival game as well
is minecraft like that i would like to
know because then i would then i would
play minecraft i mean i think kind of
there's some places you can run into
stuff like that i mean you know i think
like whenever you first meet like a
creeper and enderman that's pretty much
a jump scare right yeah you die really
easy early on so it's pretty scary